so I think there's two things that make
it unusual now one is that we're around
so this the level of co2 right now which
is around about 400 parts per million is
120 pots million higher than it was when
we started to admit much much higher
than with experience in human in the
existence of humans on earth and much
larger than then we've had co2
concentration on earth in the last
million years and probably much longer
so it has been higher in a past I mean
the dinosaurs would have much higher co2
and prior to that even higher still but
not when we've been on earth and the
second thing about global warming is it
although it's not it's not yet very
large compared to geological changes
it's very very fast the changes we can
detect from the geological record from
ice cores are often bigger but they are
much slower on the issue that that is
that complex systems like like the
climate system or like people our
ecosystems can adapt but they need time
to do it so if you push them fast as the
danger they don't adapt so I think it's
the the rate of change really that's to
keep the key unusual thing about this
period we don't know for sure whether
this is the fastest in history because
of course when you go back in time the
records tend to be more course but the
nearest to it was a period in the called
the lake palace in thermal maximum about
55 million years ago when the climate
appears to halt by something like six
degrees probably in thousands of years
and we're going in wound danger doing
six degrees and around about 100 so it's
possible and faster it's unlikely that i
think as scientists we want to see that
the politicians have taken the science
seriously and that although i mentioned
you know there are some unknowns in
climate science there there is much that
is known